hey how you doing mark hey all right hey
you know what i'm gonna ask you a
question
are you ready to die
not yet no
but you know i told this lady that i
said no i ain't ready to die she said
because you ain't living right now
who ready to die
i mean
since i believe in the universe if i die
that means i'm gonna have to feed i'm
feeding the universe the universe still
got a purpose for me that's why i'm
still here
because
man
overdosed on fitnah i don't do fitnah
but somebody gave it to me and i thought
it was mixed with my my medicine
it was like brown and white i'm like
i'm thinking it's the reds or something
right and i hit it and i just went down
fortunately the ambulance was there for
somebody else and he didn't want to go
with him he wanted his wife to come pick
him up and somehow
they came and highlighted me and
and i'm i'm down eyes open
wasn't breathing they said i was
flatlined for six minutes
now people tell me i don't want you that
man i see that like i ain't seen no
light
it was dark i don't remember that
you know and
what took me out man i had a neighbor
i used to be on i just talked [ __ ] to
him man you don't want to live you know
what i'm saying i mean you just want to
smoke smoke
i ain't giving you no more dope plus i
want to keep my own dope anyway but i
ain't giving you no more dope man you
know what i was going to feed you i
ain't give me no more dope and then
every morning i go for my little routine
bring me some crack back
and he'd be sitting out the tent this
morning he went sitting at the tent
so i said man get your ass up get up and
when i hit his leg it was stiff
stiff is a doughnut and i just looked at
him
i looked at his tummy he wasn't
breathing
and you know
i scared cause we had we got the same
illness congested heart failure
he wouldn't go get his medication man
66 years old
he wouldn't go get his medication
and
i think he just gave up
but then i started thinking man am i
giving up because i'm smoking like a
broke stove
you know
it's like i'm hustling to smoke
man
and i'm tired but am i tired physically
or spiritually because if i'm tired
spiritually i'm going to quit and i'm
not ready to quit
and i really want to know
what the universe got in store for me
man because i'm still here
i've been a motorcycle accident i hadn't
been stabbed i hadn't been shot back in
the day i mean
what is my purpose i end up from
downtown skid row
from chicago illinois
what's my purpose
am i am i uh
supposed to be with some type of uh
leader or something one day
i mean i don't know
why i'm here man i wish somebody give me
some answers because
like i say if i die
i mean i died it don't seem like i don't
know if it is the other side
because
if you die you die
you die and your spirit leaves your body
now they bring it back i i don't know
how they go
but your spirit leaves your body now if
your spirit leads your body
evidently your spirit know things i mean
you'll see something i don't remember
nothing
so oh man uh
you'll you'll find out later it'll
reveal to you later reveal to me later
man i'm so ashamed man
i'm just i'm just for some reason man
it's just i'm ashamed of myself today
i really am i'm ashamed of myself
and i don't know why
now like i said i just got they just put
me in the shelter
i'm tripping
i got my own big screen tv on the wall
i got a refrigerator i got a shower in
the bathroom
and you know what i did i went outside
took a leak
because
i'm in there by myself and i like being
by myself
but i had to get comfortable and the
only way i got comfortable i came back
down here got me some crack went to the
room and started smoking
that's only
that's the only way i got comfortable in
that room
i mean man i'm watching tv
i'm watching tombstone i love you and
throwing it the west i love it but then
it just seemed like i'm looking around
and it's quiet ain't no chaos it ain't
now i got to try to recondition myself
to something
i'm not used to
and how do you do that
just like getting ready to die huh
this lady gonna lie to me talking about
she ready now
[Music]
i don't believe nobody ready to die
nobody
because you
nobody don't know what's on the other
side if it is the other side
man i'm just like i said man i'm 55
years old man i get scared
for some reason
and i
i
might not be living right but who lives
right
nobody lives right because i got to
respond to other people sometimes the
way they come at me i got to respond
back
martin luther king talking about
turn the other cheek
[ __ ] malcolm x says if they hit you hit
him back
man how can i come on
if you disrespect me i'ma disrespect you
and i wasn't raised like that but but
being being out here
in the jungle
in the streets
oh it's lions out there
and i refused refused to be a lamb
i mean
i got to be aligned too
i got the roar oh look check it out
i got one of them uh
rambo
knives all right i started to bring it
but i didn't want mark to get up nervous
now rambo you know when he was doing
rambo he got that big old knife
i got one nail
and i love it
i love i caught one cat look he snuck in
my tent right
because you seen the bike he said hey i
ain't saying
so he got to come behind there
and i was in the tent and i unzipped it
and i and i
hit his foot
you know man
and he just took off too all right
that rainbow's so big and she now i feel
like i gotta have some type of safety
security
but now
i got shelter my own spot
and i snuck it in there with me
what my mom mama you tell me well you
ain't got the sis
the man upstairs gave you
i'm like
i do well use it
and they say common sense ain't too
common
and man i come and go sometimes i really
do i'll come and go
but i ain't gone
i ain't going at all man because
sometimes i space out sometimes
and i believe everybody do as time go
back
man they don't lie
so much to me
growing up
i don't even believe i don't believe
they went on mars or to the moon i mean
if you went to the moon
why you only went one time
one time so all the mother rockets went
up there
all this technology you got now didn't
make it but back in the end they had no
goddamn technology no top of the line
[ __ ] they made to the moon
you went one time
i mean
give me a camera
i can alternate some [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i mean i don't
i don't i don't believe in stuff
i mean
you say stuff
and and stop and have my mind to go the
way you want to go or have my man go
whichever way it go and have me believe
in some [ __ ]
and see man i'm so lost man and
sometimes
since i get high
i think i enjoy being lost
because i don't have to understand that
it's hard to understand [ __ ]
you know
it really is hard to understand
something man because
i mean i i want to know my purpose on
this universe
and i'm not trying to say i want to do
the purpose now because if i do it now
universe might take me
i don't want
i won't know my purpose but i don't want
to do my purpose until i'm like 80.
because
when i hit the 90s they say you come in
as a baby you leave out as a baby i
don't want to be wearing no diapers
no no so i figure 80 82 maybe 85
okay universe can take me but let me do
my purpose first
i mean
i've been trying to i've been cooking
out here just to get my comfortability
back when i was out here
because that's what i did
i i'm a cook that's what i that's that i
love doing that
i started that when i was 18 years old
that's all i know
so i think let me go back but then i had
to think about i'm not 18 no
more so now i'm trying to hold on to
some [ __ ] in the past
to make me feel good
so
i got some type of void in my life
that i'm trying to find out how to feel
it
and the only thing i'm filling it out
with is drugs
that's why i'm feeling that void right
now because i don't have anything else
to fill that void with
i think everybody got a void in their
life
but some people
rich people fill it with money
some people fill it with sex
you got a void your body just you you
feel your voice with helping people
that's you that's that's
your voice your life the way you feel
your void mark is helping people
everybody got a void they might not know
it
but you got to fill the void with
something
and yours is helping people giving
people a chance helping people eat help
them
express themselves
that's how you fill in your void
and that's not right ain't nothing wrong
with that
hey anybody younger than me
you might be older than me
yoda oh you look goddamn good
you know man
and i know y'all gonna tell you what i'm
saying your age because you might have
one of them whipping snappers get you
hey
i only know how the one way to feel my
voice i had that voice since i was a kid
since since i i met the boogie man
that's what and when i met him
and grandma
[Music]
and my people
i had a void man
and that's the only way like i said man
i was drinking when i was five pops used
to give me hearty tardies whiskey and
lemon and give me beers and watch me
you know fall asleep on the floor
and had a friend
mother used to give us weed
in fifth grade one joint every day but
we had to go to his house and smoke it
in this room his mom allowed us to go
upstairs in the room and smoke it and we
just go in his backyard and play
basketball
ever since then i've been feeling that
well that's what helped me fill that
void and as time went by it just
increased
it increased
i
i don't care if
if you like me
i'm not trying to fit in i'm not trying
to be a part of i'm not trying to people
please
some people do that
fill a void
and i see i had to start thinking about
life when she told me you know dead man
don't tell no tales
but when she told me
i ain't living right because i told her
i ain't ready to die i said you ready
she's okay i'm ready i see you're lying
[ __ ]
no you ain't ready to die
if you got family if you got grandkids
you got kids your mother you ain't ready
to die
don't tell me it sounds good
sounds damn good
i mean y'all people ready to die out
there raise your hand
i don't see none
cause ain't nobody ready to die
i wanna live as long as i can listen to
my 80s
and i and hopefully
let me put it like this hopefully i can
learn how to live
instead of existing because right now
i'm just existing i ain't living
i know i might be alive but i ain't
living
it's two different things in living and
existing
you believe that mark
and you're living right now see what i'm
saying you're living because you're
doing what you want to do and you're
helping people
the way you want to feel your void i
don't want to feel my void like this but
i don't know no other way because i
don't know what the
universe has in store for me man
i thought when i was a kid man i wanted
to be an engineer because i was in
grammar school i just hit a big old
uh uh engineer in the big old
i liked it that but as time went by
i was a hell of a basketball player
when i graduated high school
my first job was an emmy street hotel
i was a cook
they said man you wanna i was a busboy
they said man i used to stay at these
cats because they were sharp he was like
you know that's a yeah they pulled me
back that i was 18 years old i've been
cooking since 55.
i didn't ran kitchens i didn't write the
rich ma rich cartoon industry hotel the
marriott the margin in west hollywood
the bellagio was how they were selling
ranching was how they were
what they said i ain't new at this i
agree with this
but somehow
i got distorted
i lost my weight
and it's a trip how
my mind is insidious because they tell
me [ __ ] and i listen
i listen and i know damn well
that wasn't the thing to do i mean one
time man
every time i got paid i just go get out
i had family and everything
one day
my wife woke up she said oh i'm so happy
you still in the house i said to myself
[ __ ] i fell asleep
i would have been gone when you fell
asleep but i fell asleep and you had me
when you woke up i was just still here
and i hate to say that but that was my
routine
if you didn't get no money out of me
before i
i was gone
that's a shame and my wife my ex-wife
should be like i don't know where you
get that [ __ ] from your daddy wasn't
like that and i used to be like my try
to be like my daddy but my mama used to
tell me boy you ain't your daddy
so now
i got identity problems now i got to
find out who i am and never found out
who i was
throughout all these years
oh yeah i know my name
but do i know me
because if i know me i wouldn't be doing
the [ __ ] i do i wouldn't put myself in
situations i put myself in if i know me
so it's a trip when a person try to
out-think themselves
so i'm trying to out-think me
and a friend of mine told me they used
to he was intolerant they say man
how can you fix something
with the man that put you in that
something
i said huh he said how can i fix
something
with my mind put me in
to fix something i said but i understand
what he's saying you know what i'm
saying i mean i'm trying to fix
something with the man that put me in
the situation i'm in that ain't gonna
work
it's not gonna work cause i keep trying
to do it
55 keep trying to do it
so now i have to change my thinking so
if i change my i've been like this
oh
30 40 50 something years
maybe 50 i found 50 years so all of a
sudden you think i'm gonna change my
thinking a week or two and everything's
gonna be all right i got to live another
50 40 something years just to match that
just to really be able to fight with it
just to really fight with myself to
condition myself
and be able to handle myself it's gonna
take damn near that and i ain't i don't
think i'm gonna live that god damn long
so do i keep being me
or find out who i am
because once i leave here that man don't
tell no tails
and i won't be able to say nothing
and see when i leave it i won't i won't
oh oh man he was he was all right man
that cat was all right
family i want family talking back oh he
was
i mean when i passed rest in peace i
don't i
i don't want them talking bad about me i
want my picture on the wall in the house
oh yeah that's my son
it's a lot of things i think about now
man because i'm scared
okay let me i just admitted i am scared
to die because i ain't living right i
respect that what she said but like i
say who lives right
tell me how to live right
how can i live right
nobody can't tell me that oh be kind to
people i do be kind to people
uh or do what i do do for other people
up
what else
i can't get another vine got it
so how do you live right
nobody can't tell me that
people live the way they live on a daily
basis
you live the way you live i live the way
i live
so so so
the way you live
i don't know what you do when you leave
here
he might party in three photos
i don't know
but that's not living right
but down here you're living right you
look like you're living right
i'm telling you
so so nobody can't tell me how to live
right and see all this [ __ ] i can sound
good i can tell you what to do with your
life but i don't apply it in my life i
don't play my own words
and i'm not trying to make myself look
good for you
i'm being me
and i enjoy being me but i have a void
in my life man
and i need to fill that void with
something else man
because now
i don't want to
be in the shelter man and then end up
[ __ ] it off
end up coming back man i know a couple
of people
quite a few people who was in the place
where i met
had their own
sheltered room everything keep
everything feed you three thousand [ __ ]
they watch you call everything
you ain't gotta do nothing you ain't
gotta pay for nothing just be there
compute
communicate with your case work on a
weekly basis that's it you're gonna get
section eight they're gonna make you you
got income
and get you housing
but sometimes that [ __ ] scared me
because now i got a responsibility to
once you give me rent now i got to pay
some rent i can't smoke
and see now i can identify with some of
these cats that want to stand 10 because
i ain't got to pay no rent oh y'all
going to come feed me
you know what i'm saying i ain't got no
responsibilities i can smoke smoke smoke
all day
i can understand that because i didn't
relate
i identified with it
instead i was tripping because before
the day they came and got me to take me
there i started tripping like
i felt uncomfortable
because i don't want to leave and come
back looking like a fool
that's what happened to me that's the
only reason i didn't go to college
i offered to play basketball in college
oregon oregon state university arizona
i was in a basketball player but
everybody on my block went to college
and came back and said one guy he
graduated from northwestern
and i got scared and i didn't go to
college that's when i went got my job at
mbc sweet hotel
maybe my life would have been better
different if i went to college maybe
maybe i would have been strung out even
more
because they partied in college
and i was already partying before i was
going to college
so i
i got intimidated i got scared once
again
and fear
fear
[ __ ] up my life a whole lot
and they say the acme for fear is false
evidence appearing real
fear false evidence appearing real
and i believe that because
fear
fear knocked me back man but it ain't
false evidence because it's real to me
because i feel it
if i feel something it's real
they say go with your gut feeling
that's what i do
but see
if i don't go with the inside
this takes over
and like i said it's sidious it's
insidious
they tell me some [ __ ] and i listen
so now i got to learn how to separate
the right from wrong
and
and they say if you know better you do
better [ __ ]
i know better and i still do the goddamn
[ __ ] i do
so don't tell me no [ __ ] like that you
know better you do better that [ __ ]
sounds good
sometimes i think people just like to
sound good for themselves because i
don't want to hear that [ __ ]
i know but i know right from wrong and i
still do some [ __ ]
when i be going to do my thing man i'd
be tripping on myself i'd be looking at
cars
that's not even my goddamn thing
look at that what [ __ ] i'm looking at
the coffer because the doping i'm going
to go with it
goddamn right
and that's not my style
that's not my style mark
but but
i'm trying to fill a void
in my life
and i don't know how to fill a void
and i'm looking for anything
really
you feel that void
hey boy man
it's a whole
deep
deep me
in my gut
in my heart i'm lost
it's a void that i need to feel
and i'm searching for anything to feel
it
one time i finished i was in the chat
hello i
had a female i mean man she said baby
if you never did this don't do it
because it's gonna feel good
and i didn't do it cause she said that
cause i'm gonna do it just because she
was doing it and she was feeling good
and i want to feel good
i want to feel good i smoked concern one
day now i end up on 122nd in maine how
the [ __ ] i get here
don't remember nothing trying to fill a
void
man i'm searching man i'm searching i'm
searching
do i got to go somewhere else's church
do i go to another city and search but
i'm still taking me with me
so i guess i'll be searching there too i
want to go to miami they say man me cool
you know what i'm saying
but [ __ ]
i ain't gonna do number trick off in my
hand because they see a lot of beautiful
women out there
let me know i gotta take some money to
go to madmen you know i mean oh
they say there's [ __ ] throws out there
24 hours a day [ __ ] don't don't close
oh i'm gonna have a ball
taking me with me
what the progress said
progress
i need i need some type of progress i
need to feel good about myself man i
don't feel good about myself
the boy has me [ __ ] i don't
i ain't no follower man
i look at people man
why this [ __ ] so happy man
he down here with me what the [ __ ] he
doing what happened
he didn't know what i'm doing and then
oh his k his family came and picked him
up okay you got family in your life
that's how you
feel your boy
it's all right
hey
the family is very important to have
family and friends
i always talk
family and real friends it's like your
family is very important to have in your
life
you need them
you need to
that's my mother and i realize this one
with my boys there
thank you
family
oh nobody talking bad about me
oh my god
you know what when my neighbor passed
away man you know i kept this stuff
there for them in two weeks
because uh
this girl said why the [ __ ] you keep
coming down here
i said why you go over this family she
said we were his family
we want his family man
that's why he kept coming down here
we put him in the hospital we call
everybody
he wouldn't leave programs i feel come
back down here with us
and i realized that we were his family
and i used to talk [ __ ] to him it's all
bad to him because i want him to
get your medication man you gonna die
i'm not ready to die i can't help you
live while i die man
i only can do so much man
he said man let him be i said i can't
let him be man because that's not me i
wasn't raised like that i can't let them
be man how can i let him be
you he that's why he won't equal small
crowd that's just like me if my auntie
got cancer you think i'm gonna give him
some goddamn cigarettes
do you think i'm going to give up some
secrets and everyone quick
in your life
do every
everybody
has a void in life man
people just know
whatever they fill in the void with i
guess they comfortable with it
but when i'm feeling with my boy with it
i'm not comfortable with it
because i know
i'm a better person than i am
a better person than i am here
i was raised like this
i want condition like this
but i lost my weight
i took a wrong turn somewhere i made a
wrong decision
somewhere
not supposed to be all right with it
because i'm living
oh oh cause i'm existing
i'm supposed to be all right
yo it's gonna be all right yeah it's
gonna be where it's gonna be all right
i'm 55.
what are you gonna be all right well i'm
jennifer
yeah
it's gonna be all right once i fill this
void to where i want to feel it
so it can make me happy
i want to be happy man
i'm
tired escaping mentally
i escaped mentally man
i want to stop feeling good man
about myself
i don't even feel good about myself man
so if i ain't feeling good about myself
that mean i don't even love myself
because i love myself i treat myself
if i love myself
so if i don't love myself about the hell
i can love somebody else man
man i appreciate you my come here i
guess
i get a lot of [ __ ] out man
i get a nice [ __ ] out
and i feel better
because when i'm out there
i have to be
super man of steel superman
batman my favorite character
but i got to be the man of steel out
there
because they can't show no weakness man
because they will eat your ass up cause
you so weak with me i'ma eat your ass up
same way
and drugs
you know they don't
suppress your feelings and mitigate your
feelings [ __ ] i've been getting help
all week
and i still feel
i still feel so that [ __ ] really
talk about drugs medication
cause i still feel
and i do it so i won't feel
so
what's my purpose
what's my purpose man
tell me what's my purpose
i'm just a lost individual
i'm gonna tell myself it's gonna be all
right
i lied myself before
it ain't nothing new
my pops you chill man pops i [ __ ] up
again i knew you've been doing that all
your life boy
you know what
hey man you tripping oh you dripping
so uh
it's alright to tell myself that
you know one thing is do i believe it
hey man i appreciate your mark man you
help me get some of this stuff off man
thanks john
i got love for you man thank you man
keep doing what you're doing feel your
void mark
thank you
you